[Musique]
j'ai perdu mes parents
cette souffrance
a fait de moi ce que je suis
j'ai consacré ma vie à essayer de
redresser les torts du passé
comme si combattre le crime allait
ressusciter mes parents
toi tu as réussi
j'ai du mal à imaginer ce que tu as
enduré
perdu ta mère et ton père le même jour
j'ai remonté le temps pour sauver mes
parents
et au final
j'ai complètement détruit l'univers
si tu es retourné changer le passé ce
monde doit mourir
tu as changé de futur
tu sais ce que représente ce symbole
il représente l'espoir
je t'aiderai à combattre
tu veux jouer les dingues
on va jouer les dingues
je dois défaire ce que j'ai fait
ce sont nos blessures
qui font de nous ce qu'on est on n'est
pas censé revenir en arrière pour les
guérir
ne laisse pas ce drame définir ta vie
[Musique]
quoi qu'on fasse
jamais on pourra rattraper ça non
personne doit mourir
[Musique]
vous êtes équipés de parachute et il est
où le tien
[Musique]